i feel like he holds you to a really  high standard i think he's also seen  what i can do realistically i had an  autoimmune disorder and i don't anymore  and then my mom had arthritis and she  doesn't have arthritis anymore when he  had something called akathesia from  these stupid benzodiazepines i was the  one who said this is academia this is a  drug reaction all the doctors we went to  in north america were like no it's some  underlying condition i took them to a  different country where they recognized  what was going on that and i've been  making financial decisions and doing  brand management and project management  i think he's pretty happy with me at the  moment